well it's nice to virtually meet
everyone
my name is andrew you've got tyler here
as well hey guys
and we're excited to talk to you about
the matrix profile api
this is a code base that we've been
working on and we believe it presents a
novel solution to time series data
mining that you can use in several
different languages
so a little bit more detail about where
we'll be going in this presentation
we'll start out by giving you some
background about the matrix profile
foundation
well that answer the burning question
what exactly is the matrix profile
we'll highlight a number of use cases
and applications that the matrix profile
is great for
we'll talk about the matrix profile api
specifically
and how you can use it to quickly get up
to speed on using the matrix profile
and then we'll wrap up by discussing
some of our specific libraries and other
resources that you can take advantage of
so who is the matrix profile foundation
well you've already met tyler and myself
but along with frankie cancino jack
green and francisco bishop
we are a group of open source software
developers that are devoted
to promoting the matrix profile data
structure as well as the associated
algorithms that are used to compute
and leverage it now that sounds like a
pretty strong claim why would a group of
people be so interested
in promoting something like the matrix
profile and spending all this time on it
and that's because we believe that the
matrix profile is a revolutionary new
way to approach time
series analysis so a little more
specifically
the matrix profile is a data structure
and a set of associated algorithms that
solves the dual problem of anomaly
detection
and motif discovery now for anyone who's
worried about extensive mathematical
notation
don't worry we're not going to do that
in this presentation
we're going to focus on visual examples
that will hopefully make some of these
points clear
it's also worth calling out that the
matrix profile does have
applications for both batch and
streaming processes
now this is not something we're going to
get into but you can feel free to reach
out to us to learn more about this
through some of our resources at the end
all right so just some background on the
matrix profile this
illustration here will give you an idea
of how how it's computed
so the distances are actually based on z
normalized euclidean distance
if you can recall euclidean distance
values that are closer to zero represent
similarity whereas values further away
from zero mean
that they're dissimilar so in this
example we're actually computing the
distances across the time series
starting at the second
subsequence once all the distances are
computed
an exclusion zone is applied to avoid
trivial matches
and the minimum distance is captured and
the matrix profile distance is below
so the exclusion zone is actually
important to avoid the trivial match
and a trivial match is considered to be
something
that is a match on itself or a match
very similar in that region
so the first use case we're actually
going to discuss is pattern mining
so this is known as motifs in the matrix
profile
verbiage
so here's a synthetic time series
plotted below
and it should make it very clear what a
motif is in this use case
we actually computed the matrix profile
using a subsequence
length of a 32 so that means that
there's 32 observations per subsequence
and if you recall that 32 length
subsequence is slowed across the entire
time series and all the distances are
computed
the representation of the matrix profile
is plotted below
you can see that there's a couple
valleys there
on around 600
and a little before that representing
repeated patterns
we'll see how this looks in close up
on the next slide here you can see that
there's
one motif pair found and the
small subsequences of those ot pairs
are plotted so looking at it from a
zoomed out
zoomed out view and relative to the time
series itself
we can see that the first motif is
highlighted in red
whereas neighboring subsequences are
highlighted
in black these highlighted
subsequences the neighboring
subsequences
can actually be the second third fourth
or fifth degree
uh and this is all parameter tuning
the second and third motif pairs
actually don't have any neighbors based
on the parameters that we set
moving on to another common use case
with matrix profiles is anomaly
detection
these are also known as discords in
matrix profile speak
so this data set here is actually the
new york city taxi data set where
there's passenger counts
summed up on a 30-minute interval
excuse me you can see below that the
red stars denote the dischords and if
you recall the euclidean distance
concept that zero means something
similar
whereas something larger than zero means
dissimilarity
you can definitely see that here
visually in the matrix profile plot
below
another important use case for
time series analysis is something called
pattern summarization
so imagine that you want to visually see
what's the most common pattern across my
whole time series
in this case we have a pretty trivial
example where we concatenated two time
series together of pigs
and they were cut to measure their
arterial blood pressure the first time
series in blue
is the first pig and the second is an
off pink color
so looking at the snippets we have this
plot here
the snippets actually highlighted in red
and
the subsequences most similar to that
snippet
are highlighted in orange and note that
it represents the first pig
that we saw
so looking at the second snippet it is
coincidentally
the second peg and representing
all those subsequences as well
another common use case or other ways
how to how you could apply this is
thinking of it in an ekg setting where
you're measuring a patient's heartbeat
you can see what's normal for that
patient
over a given period of time
another important and useful
analysis tool is clustering with time
series
so matrix profile has this new distance
measure called
mpdist and it considers two time
series to be similar if many
subsequences
are similar to one another regardless of
the order
and that's something important to note
here because order matters
in some use cases in this use case
uh you could see that in cluster one
that the order definitely doesn't matter
because
the spacing between the peaks
are further out whereas if you use
something like dynamic time warping this
would actually
be a huge factor based on the warping
window
now tyler has already walked us through
several very compelling examples
of the matrix profile so your next
question might be
how much effort is it to code up these
analyses are we talking hundreds of
lines of code like how complex is this
well by developing the matrix profile
api
or mpa which is a common codebase in
python r and golang
we believe we've made it extremely easy
for you to do all of these analyses on
your own data
now the mpa is structured in a way that
matches how you normally think of
applying the matrix profile
the first thing you do is you compute
the matrix profile the second piece is
do you
have to discover something about the
matrix profile a couple of examples
we've seen
are using the matrix profile to discover
discords or to discover motifs
as well as specific time series snippets
now once you've discovered something you
need to visualize it
in a way that makes sense to you and to
the audience you're conveying this
information to
now we have taken those three core
functionalities
and we've wrapped them into a single
high level functionality called
analyze this is our user for any it
friendly interface for beginners
where you can simply pass your time
series directly in
and start pulling out some of these
applications that we've already shown
now as you become more familiar with the
matrix profile with mpa
you can dig further into each of the
core components and this will enable
further exploration so that your
analysis can become
even more powerful
now as we mentioned before you can visit
all of our code and see it on github we
have our python implementation known as
matrix profile
our r library tsmp our golang library
known as go matrix profile
and for those of you who are
specifically interested in pure
similarity search we have a bonus python
library called mass ts
so you can learn more about us at our
website matrixprofile.org
you can talk with us and interact with
us on our discord channel
you can feel free to tweet us at matrix
profile or visit us on linkedin
so thank you very much for listening to
our presentation and
good luck motif hunting